[Music]
the ancient greeks were emphatic that
philosophy
was not just an elaborate abstract
exercise
it was they felt a deeply useful skill
that should be learnt and practiced by
all
in order to help us to live and die well
no one believed this more than plato
who was passionate in his defense of
philosophy as a kind of therapy for the
soul
one of the most forceful stories he told
on behalf of the utility of philosophy
was what has become known as the
allegory of the cave
it is perhaps the most famous allegory
in philosophy
this was a story that was intended as he
wrote to compare the effect of education
and the lack of it on our nature at the
start of book seven of his masterpiece
the republic
plato tells us about some people living
imprisoned in a cave
they've always lived there and don't
know anything of the outside world
there is no natural light in this cave
the walls are damp and dark
all the inhabitants can see comes from
the shadows of things thrown up on the
wall by a light of a fire
the cave dwellers get fascinated by
these reflections of animals plants and
people
moreover they assume that these shadows
are real
and that if you pay a lot of attention
to them you'll understand and succeed in
life
they don't of course realize that they
are looking at mere
phantoms they chat about shadowy things
enthusiastically
and take great pride in their
sophistication and wisdom
then one day quite by chance someone
discovers a way out of the cave
out into the open air at first it's
simply overwhelming
he is dazzled by the brilliant sunshine
in which everything is for the first
time properly illuminated
gradually his eyes adjust and he
encounters the true forms of all those
things
which he had formally known only as
shadows he sees
actual flowers the colors of birds the
nuances in the bark of trees
he observes stars and grasps the
vastness and sublime nature of the
universe
as plato puts it in solemn terms
previously
he had been looking merely at phantoms
now
he is nearer to the true nature of being
out of compassion this newly enlightened
man decides to leave the sunlit
upper world and makes his way back into
the cave
to try to help out his companions who
are still mired in confusion and error
because he's become used to the bright
upper world he can hardly see anything
underground
he stumbles along the damp wet corridors
and gets confused
he seems to the others totally
unimpressive
when he in turn is unimpressed by them
and insists on explaining what the sun
is or what a real tree is like the cave
dwellers get sarcastic
then very angry and eventually plot to
kill him
the story of the cave is an allegory of
the life of all enlightened people
the cave dwellers are humans before
philosophy the sun
is the light of reason the alienation of
the returned philosopher
is what all truth-tellers can expect
when they take their knowledge back to
people
who have not devoted themselves to
thinking for plato
we are all for much of our lives in
shadow
many of the things we get excited about
like fame the perfect partner
a high status job are infinitely less
real than we suppose
they are for the most part phantoms
projected by our culture
onto the walls of our fragile and flawed
minds
but because everyone around us is
insisting that they are genuine
we are taken in from a young age it's
not our fault individually
no one chooses to be in the cave that's
just where we happen to begin
we're all starting from a very difficult
place if
like the man in plato's story you
bluntly tell people they're wrong
you get nowhere you cause deep offense
and may endanger your own life
athens had after all recently put
socrates plato's friend to death
plato knew from close experience just
what the cave dwellers might do
to those who claim to know the sun the
solution plato says
is a process of widespread carefully
administered philosophical education
by which he understood the method of
inquiry pioneered by socrates
are known to us as the socratic method
it's a very gentle process
you don't lecture or harangue or force
someone to read a particular book
you just start with a general
declaration of intellectual modesty
no one knows very much it's always good
to insist and wisdom starts with owning
up to ignorance
confess that you don't know exactly what
the government should do
what war is meant to achieve or how good
relationships work
you then get the other person to say
what they think and gradually together
you investigate the answers most likely
the other person will be confident or
rather painfully
overconfident they may tell you it's all
quite simple really and everyone knows
the answer already
you must be supremely patient with this
kind of bravado
if they go off topic you must cheerfully
double back
you must take a lot of time and be ready
to have chats over many days
this method of talking is founded on a
lovely confidence
that with the right encouragement people
can eventually
work out things for themselves and
detect errors in their own reasoning
if you carefully and quietly draw their
attention to tricky points
and don't cast blame or ever get annoyed
you never teach anyone anything
by making them feel stupid even if they
are at first
we have all started in that cave but it
is plato's deepest insight
that we don't have to stay there and the
road out is called
quite simply philosophy this is the sun
whose light we can follow
and by whose rays the proper nature of
things can become
clear if you enjoy the films on this
channel
you might want to hear about another
smart insightful channel we love
called wisecrack click here to visit
their channel page
and discover a succession of videos on
world literature
philosophy cinema history and more all
delivered with a playful beguiling sense
of humor
there in la we're here in london but the
school of life and wisecrack
have become firm friends based around
shared values
about making education compelling we'd
love you to befriend us both in turn